The Long Term Plan or LTP is now open
for your feedback and guess what?
Here it is, we're trying to get
a summation in under a minute.
Mayor Dan, rates, you're trying to keep them low?
Yes we are and Council's looking to defer
major or new projects where possible.
But the District's still got issues, problems
that it will have to face over the next 10 years?
Yes there is and there are four key areas
that the Council will be focusing on.
Don't want to put you under pressure,
but you've got 40 seconds, what are they?
They are ensuring our community facilities
can cater for our growing population.
Supporting Waimakariri's
Covid-19 economic recovery.
Preparing for the impacts of climate change
and improving our District's sustainability,
and looking at how the Government's upcoming
three waters reform would impact us.
That's four, well done! So that's
the LTP in a nutshell and we're going
to have more information in coming
videos. Yes, there's coming videos.
To find out more visit
waimakarariri.govt.nz/letstalk